the political fight over the dueling
memos in the Russia investigation is
intensifying the White House said Friday
that President Trump will not release a
classified memo drafted by Democrats on
the House Intelligence Committee and it
is intended as a rebuttal to a
Republican memo released last week
Republicans and Democrats have clashed
over the increasingly politicized battle
about the memos the GOP memo detailed
allegations that the FBI abused its
surveillance powers during the Russia
investigation Paula Reid is in our
Washington bureau with the latest Paula
good morning good morning the White
House cited national security concerns
as the reason the president is blocking
the release of the Democrats memo in a
letter to the committee White House
Counsel Don Magan says the memo contains
properly classified and especially
sensitive passages he asked Democrats to
consult with the Justice Department and
revise the memo but just last week the
president released a classified memo on
the same subject crafted by Republicans
that memo charges that the FBI and
Justice Department were not completely
honest when seeking a warrant to monitor
the communications of former Trump
campaign adviser Carter Paige now the
central charge in that Republican memo
was that those officials didn't disclose
the political origins of an as-of-yet
unverified dossier that document was
drafted by former British intelligence
officer Christopher Steele and they
didn't disclose it during their request
for the surveillance warrant now Deputy
Attorney General rod Rosenstein and FBI
director Christopher ray have outlines
specific concerns about releasing this
Democratic memo as is in a letter to the
White House they specifically point to
the need to protect intelligence
gathering sources and methods the
Democrats point out that the Justice
Department and FBI had the opportunity
to review the memo for more than a week
before the White House made its decision
known the president Declassified the
Republican memo over objections about
material emissions from both of those
same officials now the White House says
the president is still inclined to
release the memo in the interest of
transparency if revisions are made Alex
Paula what is
the impact of all this back and forth
over the memos in terms of intelligence
gathering will it be interesting to see
because right now federal law
enforcement agencies they share
classified and sensitive information
with this committee with an expectation
that the committee will use it in a
discreet nonpartisan way but here you
have members of both parties trying to
publish this sensitive information and
also bipartisan cooperation on this
committee is it an all-time low in fact
some staffers on this committee are
planning to erect a physical wall
between Democratic and Republican
staffers because of so much feuding so
it's hard to live up to the spirit of
that arrangement under these kinds of
conditions Alex Paula Reid in Washington
thanks Paula